hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play to never sleep I gotta go
back and find out what the hell happened
this like a monster I don't know I
didn't see anything I didn't turn around
but it was like something I don't know
like all the sudden the chase music
certain I just know I played it easy
enough to know that that means get the
[ __ ] out of there but I got acid for
whatever reason I got it
I'm not really worried about oil
consumption at the moment because I got
a B it noses nothing to be worried about
assuming that I'm done with this area so
maybe I got to start backtracking now
shut up spider just in case something
happens
I don't know what
this is where I saw my first monster
song but it's hard to remember where
I've been oh man I'm so bad turn around
dungeon entrance this way old barrels
okay this is where I thought maybe if I
stack up I can get up there but I did
okay let me go back to the dungeon
entrance I got I got acid for whatever
reason I I don't know why I don't have
any notes or mementos err I'm just
confused at the moment so Prison easily
wait when did these been here never seen
did I miss these completely
okay Wow a lot of work went into this
custom story I can say that oh this is
where we keep all prisoners are you
careful not to go near the prison door
why what will happens there's no way
none unless the doors are open we are
then the servants will take care of the
servants I bet I know who the servants
are
that is going to be utterly confusing
trying to navigate for here backtrack so
much and no goodies
okay big nicely made some of the stuff I
don't recognize so this is must be some
interesting still I'm very nervous that
nothing has happened besides that one
little bit like the atmosphere is like
totally ah the torture room lovely
didn't he mention something about
torturing with the acid why am I going
in
Oh Oh
[Music]
I know I know owner who's you who's that
screw you shut up
oh this is why I needed the acid Oh
anyone there I am what should I do
there must be some kind of lever to
release constraints hello oh I know yeah
this lever isn't gonna release you I bet
I bet I'm bad watch this
sorry no I knew was he's gonna do what
the hell what the hell whoa hey back off
whoa
what done how did it how did I what
Oh what I'm like what the hell is going
on wha okay not going down there how
about that oh oh
let's go
I'm top top what why
[Music]
I thought I recognized those noises
a bit date string there's somewhere in
here oh oh okay anyway I bet they used
to ignore someone in here cuz there seem
to be a lot of doors going everywhere
what did I get good key to the car oh
hey castle outside that's right
doors over there already been up that
way there's nothing there oh man okay so
actually there's no way to get over
there this is all just environment okay
maybe the pretty in the East Wing is the
Easter egg hunt you spider god damn it
oh I wish this [ __ ] out he squished wish
[ __ ] off back
oh [ __ ] out okay there is now a water
monster down there
y-yeah I have have a key to a door
somewhere
oh wait a minute
this wasn't it okay nothing here it
wasn't in here think I remember there
being one locked door
I [ __ ] spiders
why this number
[Music]
where they're monsters
and what's there something that I need
to get
that looks like it could be something
together
[Music]
secret red secret potato sack I don't
know I don't know
is that working from her
I'm actually running out of time but I
gotta get to a save point
close the chairs you can't help me oh
it's moving
oh hey bro okay all right I'll look for
all that later good [ __ ] this
alright thank you everybody that's all
the time I got for this episode I'm
getting the [ __ ] out of here
ah no big fighter ah okay so anyway
thank you all someone for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next part
bye back